>>> NOW, LOOK, MAYBE WHEN YOU
THINK OF WHITEWASHING A HOME,
YOU'RE THINKING HGTV, A LITTLE
BIT OF DISCOVERY ORIGINALS,
MAGNOLIA NETWORK, THINKING ABOUT
A NEW COAT OF PAINT.
BUT, NO, A MARYLAND COUPLE SAYS
THEY WHITEWASHED THEIR HOME, BUT
THEY DON'T MEAN HOME.
THEY PRETENDED TO BE WHITE IN
ORDER TO GET A FAIR APPRAISAL.
THIS IS NATHAN CONLEY.
THEY'RE BOTH PROFESSORS, BY THE
WAY, AT JOHNS HOPKINS UNIVERSITY
WHO LIVE THE IN A WEALTHY
NEIGHBORHOOD.
THEY'RE SUING A LENDER WHO
APPRAISED THEIR HOME AT
$472,000.
THE COUPLE SAID THAT WAS WELL
BELOW THE CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATE,
AND THEY WERE DENIED EVEN A
MORTGAGE REFINANCE.
SO, THEY DECIDED TO GET A SECOND
APPRAISAL.
BUT THIS TIME THEY TOOK DOWN ALL
OF THEIR FAMILY PHOTOS AND THEY
HAD A WHITE COLLEAGUE SHOW THEIR
OWN HOME.
AND GUESS WHAT HAPPENED THIS
TIME AROUND.
THE VALUE SHOT UP TO $750,000.
THOSE OF YOU DOING MATH AT HOME,
THAT'S NEARLY $300,000 IN
DIFFERENCE.
AND THIS IS NOT AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT.
IT ALSO HAPPENED TO THIS BLACK
COUPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
OH, AND TO A BLACK HOMEOWNER IN
INDIANAPOLIS.
I WANT TO BRING IN SOMEONE WHO
IS ACCOUNTABLE ON THE ISSUE OF
RACIAL BIAS AND HOUSING AS PART
OF A NEW SEGMENT WE'RE CALLING
"THE CONVERSATION" WHERE WE GO
BEYOND THE HEADLINES, BEYOND THE
SOUND BITES, AND DIG DEEPER INTO
THE REAL ISSUES.
MARCIA FUDGE IS SECRETARY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT.
AND SHE JOINS ME HERE TONIGHT.
MADAM SECRETARY, WELCOME.
I'M REALLY GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU.
>> MADAM SECRETARY, I HAVE TO
TELL YOU, THE IDEA FOR SOME OF
THIS NOTION OF HAVING TO
WHITEWASH A HOME OR EVEN
WHITEWASHING A HOME TO GET A
DIFFERENT APPRAISAL, IT MIGHT BE
STUNNING TO SOME, NOT PERSONALLY
STUNNING TO ME.
I GREW UP IN A HOUSE WHERE MY
PARENTS WERE OFTEN DENIED
HOUSING APPLICATIONS, RENTAL
APPLICATIONS BECAUSE THEY WERE
BLACK, BECAUSE WE HAD A BLACK
FAMILY.
BUT THE IDEA IT'S HAPPENING IN
2022 IS STUNNING TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE, THAT IT'S STILL
HAPPENING.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT YOUR REACTION IS TO
THIS PERSONALLY BUT WHAT YOUR
AGENCY'S REACTION WILL BE
PROFESSIONALLY?
>> I THINK PROFESSIONALLY AND
PERSONALLY, IT IS AN ABSOLUTE
VIOLATION OF THE LAW.
IT IS A VIOLATION OF THE FAIR
HOUSING LAW.
IT IS A VIOLATION OF THE LENDING
LAW.
SO, WHAT HUD IS DOING AND WHAT
WE HAVE DONE ALREADY IS WE WERE
TASKED BY THE PRESIDENT TO LOOK
AT APPRAISAL BIAS.
IT USED TO BE THAT THESE THINGED
HAPPENED ONLY IN REDLINE
COMMUNITIES.
NOW IT IS PERVASIVE.
IT IS HAPPENING EVERYWHERE.
WE DETERMINED THAT PART OF THE
PROBLEM WAS HOW APPRAISERS WERE
TRAINED, WHO WAS IN THE
APPRAISAL INDUSTRY, AND HOW
THEY'RE GOVERNED.
SO, WHAT WE DID IN MARCH WAS TO
PRESENT A REPORT THAT SHOWED HOW
DEEPLY THIS WHOLE BIAS SITUATION
IS ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
IT IS SYSTEMIC.
AND IT IS INTENTIONAL TO SOME
DEGREE.
SO, WHAT WE HAVE ALREADY DONE,
LAURA, BECAUSE I TRY TO LOOK AT
HOW WE CAN MAKE THINGS BETTER.
WHAT WE'VE ALREADY DONE IS HAD
THE APPRAISAL SUBCOMMITTEE SAY
TO EVERY SINGLE STATE IN THIS
COUNTRY, THE TEST THAT YOU USE
IS NO LONGER VALID BECAUSE IT IS
A VIOLATION OF THE FAIR HOUSING
LAW.
>> WELL, WHAT WAS THAT TEST BY
THE WAY -- EXCUSE ME.
WHAT WAS THAT TEST?
WHAT TEST COULD YOU BE USING TO
GIVE THAT LOWER OF AN APPRAISAL
COMPARED TO IF A WHITE COLLEAGUE
SHOWS?
ARE THESE SUBJECTED CRITERIA?
IS IT NOT AN OBJECTIVE PROCESS?
>> NO, THE TEST WAS TO BECOME AN
APPRAISER.
>> OKAY.
>> THAT'S THE TEST I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
>> OKAY.
>> BUT WHAT WE HAVE LOOKED AT IS
HOW DATA IS COLLECTED.
THAT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM,
LAURA.
IT'S THE DATA.
SO, THEY COLLECT DATA AND THE
DATA IS NOT WHAT IT SHOULD BE.
THEY THEN USE THE DATA IN A WAY
IT SHOULD NOT BE USED.
SO, WE COME UP WITH THESE BIASED
APPRAISALS.
BUT AS WELL WHEN YOU LOOK AT AN
INDUSTRY THAT IS MORE THAN 95%
WHITE, YOU FIND THAT PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE TREATED DIFFERENTLY
BECAUSE THERE IS AN INHERENT
BIAS WITH A LOT OF THEM.
AND BECAUSE THEY COLLECT THE
DATA, THE DATA IS NOT GOOD DATA.
>> NOW, OF COURSE YOU CAN
IMAGINE THAT THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE WHO WILL LOOK AT THIS AND
SAY, MAYBE THIS IS JUST ISOLATED
INCIDENTS.
THE IDEA THAT THIS IS THE
PLURAL -- OUR ANECDOTE IS NOT
DATA.
THIS, AS YOU MENTIONED, IS
SYSTEMIC.
I WONDER TO WHAT DEGREE THIS HAS
EVEN BEEN LOOKED AT BEFORE.
I KNOW THAT YOU IN THE SITUATION
YOU'RE IN HAVE BEEN VERY
OUTSPOKEN ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
AND MOST PEOPLE THINK ABOUT
THESE ISSUES IN TERMS OF
REDLINING EXCLUSIVELY, NOT IN
THE APPRAISAL.
IS A NOVEL CONVERSATION THAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT HASN'T
HAPPENED BEFORE, OR THERE HASN'T
BEEN THE POLITICAL WILL PRIOR TO
NOW?
>> IT HAS NOT HAPPENED BEFORE.
THIS IS THE FIRST OF ITS KIND
REPORT.
SUBCOMMITTEE.
IT IS CALLED PROPERTY
APPRAISAL -- PROPERTY APPRAISAL
VALUATION EQUITY.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID IS
THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
EVERYTHING THROUGH A LENS OF
EQUITY.
SO, WHAT WE HAVE REALIZED IS
THAT PEOPLE SELLING HOMES, JUST
AS THE PERSON YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT, AND EVEN PEOPLE BUYING
HOMES, IF THEIR APPRAISAL IS NOT
CORRECT, WHAT WE FIND --
ESPECIALLY AS BLACK PEOPLE AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES -- IS WE
LOSE GREAT WEALTH JUST THROUGH
THE APPRAISAL PROCESS.
IF THOSE HOMES ARE APPRAISED THE
WAY THAT THEY SHOULD BE, LAURA,
THEN WE LOOK AT BEING ABLE TO
PASS DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
RESOURCES AND MORE WEALTH TO
GENERATIONS THAT FOLLOW.
BUT IF WE ARE CONSTANTLY
UNDERVALUING COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR EITHER BECAUSE THEY'RE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR OR THAT THE
PERSON THEMSELVES IS IN A
COMMUNITY THAT THEY DON'T THINK
THEY SHOULD BE IN, THEN WE
CONSISTENTLY LOSE WEALTH IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT'S WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT FROM AN EQUITY
SITUATION.
LAURA, LET ME JUST TELL YOU
ABOUT MY OWN HOME.
CAN I DO THAT REAL QUICKLY?
>> I HOPE YOU DO.
>> I LIVE IN A COMMUNITY THAT IS
TWO DOORS FROM AN ALL WHITE
COMMUNITY.
I LIVE IN AN ALL BLACK
COMMUNITY, TWO DOORS LITERALLY
FROM AN ALL WHITE COMMUNITY.
MY LOT SIZE BIGGER, MY HOUSE IS
BIGGER THAN THE HOUSE TWO DOORS
DOWN FROM ME.
BUT MY HOME IS VALUED $20,000
LESS THAN ME BECAUSE I LIVE IN
AN ALL-BLACK COMMUNITY.
IT IS PERSONAL TO ME.
WE HAVE TO FIND WAYS TO CREATE
THE KIND OF WEALTH OUR
COMMUNITIES DESERVE.
AND IF WE ARE CONSTANTLY BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST -- AND
THAT IS REALLY WHAT THIS IS.
WE CAN CALL IT BIAS IF WE WANT.
BUT IT IS SYSTEMIC RACISM AND IT
IS BUILT WITHIN MOST FEDERAL
AGENCIES AND THOSE AGENCIES THAT
WE OVERSEE.
SO, WE'RE TACKLING IT.
WE'RE NOW ADVISING FIRST-TIME
HOME BUYERS ON THEIR RIGHTS.
IF THEY GET LOWER APPRAISALS, WE
ARE DOING IT TO PEOPLE WHO SELL
PROPERTIES.
WE ARE GOING TO TRAIN THROUGH
FAIR HOUSING AND LENDING LAWS.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE THE
DATA IS COLLECTED PROPERLY, AND
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE RIGHT PEOPLE HAVE THE DA